oh that feeling when you realize there's only like
10 minutes left in the episode
I know don't revive me don't
end what a glorious day reject Nation it is time
for Loki season dose could not be more excited I
rewatched season 1 over the past couple weeks I
think it climbed to the top actually I was like
you know what I think this beats One Division
for me COI my friend he literally just shot a
very long podcast interview with uh Yuri lenthal
who plays Spider-Man map and there the voice we
got to start working on the edit for that it's
a great great interview it's going to launch on
this channel hopefully within the next week and a
half or so keep a lookout for that and John he he
helps set up the audio hell yeah for John thanks
guys all right guys well you know what to do leave
a like leave a glorious like on this video also
subscribe and click the notification Bell because
you know we're going to be covering all of Loki
and yes full length retion watch long re single
with your own copy available for super sex Rejects
at our patreon page but because this is the first
episode of season 2 it is available for the public
for free just Link in the description box lastly
massive massive thank you to all who have been
supporting the channel by getting yourself some
reject apparel at reation shop.com wearing this
citizen king shirt one of the first shirts we
ever created we just launched this shirt snip
snip from Ahsoka we got this child protection
services shirt we got this space baby shirt we got
this shirt we got that shirt we got that shirt we
got a whole bunch and September was actually
our most successful month ever so thank you
guys for helping us have a grand a month ladies
and gentlemen you know what to do reaction is
going to start now that's how we go all right
let's do it oh I'm so excited man the wait is
over oh my
goodness Pazuzu
oh man I got I'm so jacked right what is going on
Mobius it's me I don't know you yes
you do come on who Who attack of the
clo who whoa he's like that
going to the to TVA this time
K oh don't you harm Casey great shot
wow Cal your those meditation minutes
in waiting for the screen to
fall I'm fine I'm fine morning here people are
going to die from that truck yeah is the driver
fine well should be fine there we
go the organization is cracked Casey help
me please tell me you know what's going
on don't you remember me there's some Deja Vu
to it I got him I got the intruder oh damn it
whoa oh interesting displaces him in
a different time or setting I think
it' be a different time in the same setting
something terrible is happening I'm being pulled
from it is the same room same time I was in the
past oh where's Mobius they probably in Chrono
Bay 3 so no L not used to being so handheld in
by shooting the TVA handheld in these kind of
longish takes I haven't felt this level of like
excited anticipation for Marvel in a minute even
as the guy who's cool with phase 4 we tell
the people of the TVA the truth about this
place and you think people are going to be
ready to hear that got to hear the truth man
they should have the chance to live those lives
think about it everything you've been doing is
wrong and all your God you're dead ok's here he
disappeared right in front of me he looked like
he was in pain maybe Miss minutes can locate him
do not rely on Mis minutes hey I have a question
yeah jet skes seos one of these calling your name
obus maybe gently Whispering oh it's calling baby
everyone thinks that it's a personal watercraft
and it's actually a brand same way Kleenex is
oh I don't think he really cares I don't care I
care General Doc and judge gamble would like to
see you both in the War Room wonder what that's
about I'm so glad ra Al is part of the Marvel
Universe what a menacing Dreadful
start jeez man well this like a 70s
horror shot right here yeah where is
he a war room he's just pushing through Man
Poor Casey this has just been the weirdest
day so we're answering to the judges Council
now there is like a weird 70s horror way to
shooting this WOW obvious I was just doing
my job it's actually RN Slayer really owes
me the apology well God those effects are
disturbing yeah this whole thing is eerie
jeez man oh awesome
cut oh it's her from The Witcher you put out
an order to stop pruning into the microphone
Hunter we are doing this by the book and on
the record and she's from Game of Thrones
make it make sense make it make sense this
should have been the next appearance of
Kang this is like exactly what I want so
Sinister yeah I like ants you are quite a
Marvel Marvel huh you made a difference
in this war thank you for being on my
team spooky for us for all for all time
always is Rona yeah I will be proud to
lead with you oh that must be what Miss
minutes gave her oh right at the end of
uh last episode Sky hasn't fallen what sky
are you looking at are you seeing this robot
head on the table changes everything
this changes nothing I'm sorry Hunter
if we don't protect it my man we haven't been
protecting we've been destroying mhm yeah we
have to take a moment to understand we don't
happening a moment you've made your position
clear we don't have time for protocol now
succumbing to the political Dogma was a good
debate such great craftsmanship to the Symmetry
and editing Justin AAR killing this we can't go
back to pruning those branches I can do
anything she's a rogue variant you didn't
confirm someone's going to say it tell the
TVA to stop pruning effective immediately waa
hello there M you know me hey Al whenever he
enters a room it gets handheld just a moment
AG down tell me you recognize me you know
me a moment ago you didn't know me stand
down destroy the wall
Loki
oh that's who built this place
that's who stole your lives that's
who's coming back oh I just got chills
everywhere come on should hit me for a
time prun you next
time but the warnings were real seems pretty
straightforward to me what we need to know what
happened at the end of time find some soie she's
a EAS and we in this m holy [__] corruption is
deeper than we expected I just want to time to
think slow down Loki you want it time to think so
let's think it's okay this looks like it's shot
on film it's beautiful more of him that coming
that old coming you to kill the devil we need
ants that's the only way to stop him we fought
Mobius and she kicked me through a Time door well
and ask who won but it was a draw you both kicked
each other through time it's not about that guys I
wish i' had more time don't do the good what shirt
just focus on what we know we got to get a handle
on this glitching thing man that is what we know
War whoa damn see that all the ks KS he keeps us
safe I you believe that he built this place no no
how would I not remember that CU he wiped your
memories I was in the past what do you mean in
the past where in the past here here the past TVA
no there is no past TVA wow it's impossible it's
possible B timey Wy oh did you see it yeah I saw
it what is it how does it how does it look how
does it look I mean how does it feel a CR counter
it's it's all that that really I mean it look they
call this minutes no what you can't trust her
she was there a with him God their chemistry
is so good yeah I'll swing You by repairs and
advancement come on no no doctors where's that
I need to be back in there come on M I know
you're trying to help me whoa great reflection
pan we need to address the fact that you keep
disappearing I I keep disappearing we don't have
time you just disappeared I know and
I can't keep looking at it cuz it's
horrible I was lying think you're
being born or dying or both at the
same time really it's freaking
me out how does it look oh God
jeez time you're into the past that's when I
started all this all I know is I was in the
past 17 minute lunch break wait that's who
you said had my memory wiped yes he remains
is that what you're calling him or that's
his name pretty arrogant it's like calling
yourself last man standing dude this is shot
incredible it does not feel committee made and
it matches the aesthetic of the TVA really
well I have no memory of having my memory
wiped that I love that lot it's been a while
since I've been down here I mean going all
handheld really captures a disillusionment of
it all the energy is so high whereas like season
one where you're in the fantasy my man good
we're in the right place the ultimate guy in
the chair I want to introduce you to I'm or
Boris Ora Boris Boris that's awesome I call
him OB that's like a nickname I have wow how
long has it been 400 years what you got off on
the wrong floor and I told you it was the wrong
floor wait that's right yes he left immediately
god well I'm back it's great trip down memory
lane he was my last visitor wow reunited and it
feels so good hey how are the other guys doing
what other guys what other guys the W is really
pile up if I take a break so I just keep add it
forever forever sleep for all time always it's
got that strange 70s sci-fi horror there's that
Terry Gillum touched to it the set's beautiful so
how's the team doing up there you know about the
Tim Keepers in oh yeah that time slipping wait
time you know that yeah you've seen that yeah
you need fix that no impossible to time slip in
the TVA I know but we just saw it happen yeah
I'm having trouble reconciling that I'm having
trouble reconciling that he is the perfect person
to add to this world Boris um is he back 400 years
do I know you it's your future my present it's
complicated I've been pulled through different
times this match frame circles is so time slipping
in the TVA it's impossible to time slip in the TVA
but you just saw it happen yeah I'm having trouble
recing that I know look like your friend was time
slipping but it must have mean something else
because I've never seen anything close to that
happen before but you've seen it in the past
upload the memory he just got the memory it's
filling in now how did I not remember that wait
is he talking to you in the past and you're just
now remembering it wow that makes perfect sense
oh this is so strange I love it I guess time we
is possible at the TV so you remember what did
you tell them a linear time in this impossible
yes yes great editing in the future I think I
would remember that yes but it it's the future
it sure would be more convenient if we were having
this conversation in the future and this were the
past this is the never mind someone in the time
you want to end up in would need a temporal Ora
extractor do you have one of those I do not well
you've had 400 years to build one h D it Jesus can
you hold on to that until my friend mobus drops
by no wait yes I actually do have an extractor
here I love it so much Temple or extractor is
right there you need to get to the temple Loom
so the extractor can pull Loki directly out of the
time stream but if you spent too long in it that
kind of Temple energy will peel the skin right
off you not too bad compared to what Loki has to
do violently rip myself from every thread of time
and space all at once all at once so the hope is
that after you prune yourself the extractor will
pull you into the present but what's the present
his origin point but how do we decide what the
present is if it doesn't do that have you heard
about how if you fall into black hole you turn
into spaghetti no good the less you know about
that the better yep is that what Wanda did at
Mr Fantastic yes everything everywhere all at
once damn it hey no's back what you'd rather be
automically disassembled and never reassemble
again then have your skin ripped off that at least
you get to live it's a quality of life with no
skin oh it's Morse code we're
having power surges all through the
TVA what did you say uh-oh he's not having
fun anymore it's it's code is moris code
yeah timeline is branching now how bet
that's what's causing the power surges
and maybe you're time slipping really how wow
these sets temporal Loom that's bad you know
the temple Loom it's in the TVA guy book
it was one on every desk at the TVA it's
a detail index of every mechanical good
catch I can't get over how cinematic this
is I wrote it myself this is wide frames the
most beautiful sets I've seen in a long time
I this has actual movie Magic not just like
CG they're walking in a place like there's
just lubing dread and the details and the
signs the posters the floor what what I
think is great is that the TVA has always had
this 70s production design especially with
equipment and stuff and this time they're
actually choosing to hone in on the visual
language of those kind of films yeah matches
the the Aesthetics who cereb bro I I haven't
seen 2001 of Space Odyssey but that makes
me think of what everyone's told me about
2001 of Space Odyssey hav't seen Temple Loom
is the hot of the TVA it's where raw time is
refined into physical timeline what raw time
it's not constructed to weave together so many
new branches so it's overloading how horrifying
danger looms beyond the temporal Loom it looks
like a disaster it is a disaster that feeling
when you realize there's only like 10 minutes
left in the episode I know don't revive me don't
end I need to close the blast doors to protect
the TVA once those doors closed we won't be
able to resyn you so it's now or never dear
God ticking clock now but now isn't for a little
bit we still got to get mobus into position but
first h from the time stream before
I need to close the blast doors Loki
green means prune if you're too late
you will be lost to time forever and
Mobius will lose all of his skin you got about an
hour you've got about 5 minutes oh Jesus Oh
No when I use this thing I might to make it
looks like the thing a little bit especially
with that warped classic warped face design
mhm I love that they're using the falling
imagery but it's falling through time
instead of physical space like he does the the
throwback but it's falling through time Hair
Whip future not past way the future there's also
a bit of that Christopher Nolan touch on how he
would capture a Sci-Fi Story the sound design
too is really Nolan nah dude I can hear too much
of the that's dialog agent away your suit so get
down the gameway lock the temple AA extractor into
place and hoof it back to the moment I tell you
to you suit will age away you will age away and
you'll get very old and all your skin will get ped
away just keep bringing it back to that is this
cracked oh ready to see some hoing
like you've never seen before okay
mean seen it all you know love how like wow
be movie sci-fi Tech it all feels yeah he's
like so outdated dive to the bottom of
the sea or something waa waves of time
wow what a horrifying scenario beautiful
oh that's my first chills moment that is
so cool threads of time forming a rope
time great race against the clock
here wof get your suit peeled off come
on oh still
time just look how tangible and intense everything
is this is episode one they're
doing so much yikes oh boy oh
boy
no
whoa no green time try sck it's Trinity
answer it we need to close the blast do
now give him more time he can still
make it come on this does feel like
Matrix right yeah it's like about to
press the EMP yeah in a hallway move
faster Loki yeah come on dog you know
you're on a Race Against Time right
now is that is you I'm gonna get
Silvie oh Jesus three three oh not yet give him
more time sorry no no no no no no no no no no no
no what's happening there's nothing you
can do for him he's lost to time love
how it looks like musculature
under the first layer of the
suit was an alarming ass
POV yes come out oh no there you are
yes oh no
dang God that stretch Zoom
D
wow who yes beautiful oh that was awesome
we need to find Sylvie yes we do actually
the printing usually happens so so fast
but that looked excruciating what he was
going through yeah where are they going
everywhere all this for Sylvie I don't buy
it no no yeah Justin a sheepers man brilliant wo
that was brilliant oh there's new credit stuff
oh he is that an old
banana black holes I'm picking up nothing
TVA soup Isaac Bowman did great work wow
we now music I thought the writing was
good on this one too I didn't recognize
the writer's name but this suit too has
to be a tribute to some sci-fi classic
sci-fi movie feel like the design looks
familiar the cosmic stuff was straight
like Starin mixed with Kirby but I I didn't
recognize the suit it must be a movie thing
or maybe I just don't know that cos there
was a photo of them touching heads from
earlier whoa this looks like they took
a page out of the American Horror Story
credits uhoh even the credits are so
ominous uh uh uh give me one of those
I love are those kings fighting always
there the show does that they could have
yeah I think we would have noticed it
but I honestly they could have not shown
us
yes wait is this where Rono is but not 82 was
it oh she's going to McDonald's McDonald wack
ARS how do I do this what would you like
not squirrel not possum not
rats and nothing with a face
please you could have a life could be me and me
I want to try everything oh my God she's going to
be fat as hell in 20 years very quickly she won't
make it in 2023 damn that was that was brilliant
guys that was was that the best episode one that
I I mean it's theion it's the first season two
we've ever had of any Marvel property and uh yeah
episode one that was insanely great um yeah they
because the last episode of season one ended on
on on a on a great ominous horror horrific Vibe
and the there were so many theories of what what
was happening when they saw the king satue and
they didn't remember them like did they rewrite
time the king rewrite time is he an alternate
timeline and the explanation that they ultimately
gave us like oh it's genius and they work it into
the physical Stakes at what's at hand what they
got to solve like it's not just something that
they explain way and then they resolve it because
I I saw like this one very little tiny nitpick
and and it was something but then there was a one
bigger criticism that I was actually having that
I thought might have undone some of the Goodwill
of season 1 for me when I was seeing the trailers
was like oh man you know uh I like I love the
ending of season 1 it was so so menacing and
then you're like but it kind of undoes that whole
like character Arc and the journey that Loki and
Mobius went through in that season if you don't
remember each other yeah but then they solve and
then they solve it have but it doesn't feel like
course correction like no that feels like that's
maybe what the plan was the whole time maybe it
was maybe it wasn't it fits perfectly cuz this
got a new writer remember that wasn't the original
showrunner writer is not on season 2 so wal no no
no the um the woman who directed the director Kate
Harry yeah yeah sorry there's no show runners in
Marvel uh the the Kate Heron is not on this so I
don't know cuz you're right I was a little worried
about the pivot but totally played it totally
played perfectly and I know we said somewhere
during the reaction if you're listening to this
on like Spotify or apple we just watched Loki uh
season 2 episode one and we are reviewing it
right now and I was so impressed with the way
it was shot you know uh Justin and Aaron who did
moonnight which who I thought they did great work
in there and it seems like they they just kind of
got their feet wet with that and they were able to
come over here and one thing that I feel like with
Marvel the last thing I actually expected to talk
about was specifically the way this is directed
uh and like the film making behind it was the last
thing I expect weird all of the production design
cinematography dir editing the music um it and and
it it it does feel like there's a distinct voice
that is one of the biggest criticism that I feel
like we often say with Marvel is you don't feel
like like when I was revisiting season one of Loki
I was hit with the this nostalgic feeling of man
I forgot how how composed this was I I forgot just
how it felt like Kate's voice was behind this
so hearing that they were switching directors
made me go okay did they just get a Hired Hand so
they could just kind of do the show they wanted
to that's not the impression I'm getting like
what what Justin er have done there's they've I
kind of liken it to when um Doug Lyman did born
identity and then they got Paul Greengrass for
Bor Supremacy where okay now we're handheld we're
a little bit grittier and it really alien to how
the action like accelerated but it still felt
like in a world definitely but it's it kind of
adapts a little bit of Ridley Scott's uh dread
uh here because it does have this 70s sci-fi
horror touch uh Lac throughout without losing its
sense of of Wonder uh I was enamored with this uh
I I thought this was I thought this was brilliant
like just talking about like the film making right
at hand uh John what did you think of film making
no yeah I'm absolutely kind of I'm so happy right
now because I'm a little blown away because of
everything you just pointed out and Yeah like
this feels like it's crafted like it's distinct
and like this is really able I I don't know I I'm
almost at a loss for words to how to describe it
but yeah it's like they really the first season
you know felt tangible and it and it had all these
earmarks of quality film making but this you know
use of these long zooms and these you know kind
of frantic but very you know composed uh you
know like tracking shots and clearly you're like
walking around with this steady cam like there's
just so much legitimacy that that lends to the
sets to the stakes to the circumstances and
like throughout this I I I made a remark about
movie Magic and I feel like you know a lot of
Marvel movies don't give me that or Marvel things
are fun they're dazzling but they're not always
giving me that sense of like wow I am beholding
the possibilities of movie Magic and this had
that because it was like it it legitimizes all the
sets and stuff like that then where there is CGI
like you know it Blends really nicely but clearly
they're really throwing down on all these designs
and things it has humor without feeling jokey
it's for boing it's thrilling and exciting uh
and you care about each beat of the characters
Journeys as well and uh yeah I don't know this
was just so rich to me this this gave me kind of
everything I was hoping for and so much more and
it also feels like we just immediately picked up
from the end of SE season 1 and going like and
it even it's F funny that they had that back and
forth with uh uh Ki kuan's character about like
how long has it been you know because sitting
down to this I was like God it feels like Loki
was a century ago and then during the episode I
was like I feel like I just watched it yesterday
yeah you know or or like we were just doing
the the experience of of you know seeing it
the first time just yesterday or something like
that um so I mean I could go on forever but yeah
I thought this was terrific amazing koi what
did you think about Obie I love the obviously
they cast perfectly but I love especially in that
scene how the time editing and time displacement
and the sets were like full power because they
framed him in the center of a circle and then
not only did the circle slightly get Fuller for
the future and a little bit emptier for the past
but it wasn't obvious and the fact that they had
like match edited the circle behind Loki so it was
super disorienting and you felt like stuck out of
time they made you feel like you were out of time
while Loki was discovering what to do with his
being out of time like that was was genius uh
I I Justin and Aaron are are buddies of mine and I
love their work so dearly and I will totally admit
there was a part of me that was so afraid that the
world would be robbed of some of their more insane
cinematic skill by them going to a major Studio
like I I legitimately obviously love Marvel but
there's a lot of directors that can make Marvel
stuff and they can like blend their Style with the
Marvel style and that's great I'm happy for them
but I was so worried that we wouldn't get more
things like spring which is one of my favorite
horror movies ever that they did years ago and
I was so like oh this is years of their lives
and then I liked a lot of moonight but I didn't
love the ending this was what I was hoping would
happen when you hire directors like Justin and
Aaron like where they let them paint with their
paintbrushes where you let them have here's a
blank check because we can afford it but also make
the thing you'd make but in our universe that's
what Comics are to me you give a writer you trust
and an artist you trust the character and you just
say like Okay We're not gonna make coloring in
the lines too detailed but just don't do these
things but everything else just go nuts yeah and
that way you can keep it in your universe but
it's also their book that's why I like Tom Kings
Batman because it feels like his and that's why I
like what Mitch Gerards does with his characters
because they feel like hiss and this feels like
Justin and Aaron were like okay we just can't
kill Loki in the first episode because anything
else is fine and it's it's their style it's their
world it's that 70s horror it's the music that
feels original it's the production design that
feels like not just this feels like you can walk
through this set it doesn't feel like the void or
the volume whatever they call it it doesn't feel
like the volume this is that's what it feels like
to me but I I love when when things are tangible
and real and I love that two people that I really
respect got to make something to scale that still
feels like something they'd make not in this
universe yeah yeah know it feels like it's it
has this combination where it feels storyboarded
yet off the cuff at times like oh let's just watch
the actors work now let's shoot around them uh
there was such energy and vibrancy and like it's
it's literally about the the the mood of it is
a Race Against Time the structure of they keep
adding ticking clocks yeah you could feel its
rency for the the last season uh all over it
but yet completely doing uh its own thing here uh
everyone's like the the performances of obviously
Tom Heston great again I want Wilson's thumbs up
was the funniest thing to me like I couldn't hang
I I can't wait for him to get his jet ski so um
yeah the like just getting their chemistry back
feeling like man we they haven't missed a step not
one bit not one bit here have they missed the step
I I am hoping though that in some ways they do
retain some of the bit of what we love about Loki
instead of him just being like a a TVA agent this
time who's on edge you want a bit of that god of
Mischief in some capacity oh I think that's even
though he's been even though he's had a complete
character Arc you I wanted to still have a bit of
what we know about Loki you know you want a little
bit of his duplicitousness of course no I I think
that's coming I think what I'm really intrigued
by is uh the rapael casselle footage we saw in
the trailer had his him as like an actor like a
theater actor and I didn't realize he was going
to be a TVA agent and then we've also seen some
stuff where there's like yeah so I'm curious what
like Loki has to do to manipulate Rafa's character
or like how he's going to get around the TVA that
are clearly going out and hunting Sylvie that's
where I think we're going to get some Mischief in
there yeah you know last season we didn't really
like we're going to the political bureaucracy
a lot more here this time around and before it
was just kind of ravona saying [__] yeah now
there's a board now there's like a board like
okay there's like a lot more people here than just
rone it seemed like it was that it would seem like
she was answering to timekeepers timekeepers and
then there was ravona yeah right and it and last
season um so we didn't really see much of like
the political debates where clearly there's a
lot more cover upla branch she was judicial like
there's other branches going on I mean it like
Kang has create or he who remains has created such
a dichotomy for everyone such a problem that there
is that does come into question it was what it
literally was what Loki and Sylvie were arguing
about is is is telling the truth better than than
the the lie that Comforts everyone yeah can I say
before all of the internet does because we we
uh we will hear this at nauseum uh this isn't
Marvel's back but it is to me hey they can still
do that magic and they just need to like narrow
it down if we could prune some of the phase four
stuff that didn't work in the ho timeline like
Kang Dynasty I think that's what Kang Dynasty is
going to do I think Kang Dynasty is going to show
that we are on disperate timelines not everything
is Canon and then Marvel can just keep the stuff
they want and I think this show is like they still
got it yeah definitely and and I think with Kang
uh what like this was the it's so weird because
revisiting season 1 wow what a perfect setup for
king and the Multiverse consequences should have
touched it until this and and then and then uh you
know we saw what happened and and it felt like a
lot of loky SE season one ending was not really
consequential to the films and shows that came
following it that big moment everybody's like
that's the moment Everything Changes I'm like so
when do we find out what change this feels like
everything's here two years later yeah it picks
and it's like all right W I'm I'm in it and and
Kang is back to feeling it makes you forget about
his Ant-Man appearance like Jonathan you did did
a fine job as Kang in that film uh but but he was
in a different movie he was a different movie and
overall he got killed by ants well right so and
then here like ah this is the threatening guy
that we were all worried about and and just uh of
how they were clues about him Lac throughout and
you one thing I hope this show does is kind of
give you a sense of the TVA Society a bit more
seem like we got a hint of that in the opening
action scene um especially when you got all
these different characters here but then when Kang
it's I imagine that he's going to be connected to
that rona's true past is probably connected to
Victor timley right because that was what they
established in the end we're going to see Victor
timley as established in Ant-Man Quantum Mania
we're gonna see Victor timley and I imagine that's
where rona's part of her history truly lies there
as well because I think oops Sor because yeah
she left it last season she said she was going
to go look for him essentially implying that she
was going to go look for him and it seemed like
the message that Loki was playing was the thing
that was left for him and I think some of those
TVA are going to there I think they're going and I
think that's where we're going to see Rafa as the
actor right okay yeah that makes a little that's
my theory is that he's going and hunting her so
it's not just Sylvia they're going after it's also
ravona in the original timeline because if they
cut off her then we don't find out all this about
Kang and it goes back to status quo so why are
they going after Sylvie though John what are your
theories they you don't think they are I didn't
they partly establish that or at least that's
what that's Loki assumes Loki assumes but they
but the the the the old the Irish people and the
guy who like she's Scottish they Scottish whatever
they said they said we have to go after Sil we
have to get Sil they said it in the boardroom
and B15 would say that but then B15 said this
is scen success I think it's not Jess Sylvie or
it's a mislead but what did they need to go after
Sylvie but maybe they know more than the rest do
at least the the woman from Game of Thrones seem
to know more the woman from The Witcher seemed
more earnestly uh surprised surprised by this
Revelation whereas the women from Game of Thrones
seemed to be like more aware more in control and
trying to just not let that on so much so I wonder
if maybe she has got some kind of awareness of
he who remains or the truth of the matter and
is trying to maintain and protect the lie that
everybody lives under or something I guess would
be because you know if s if she knows Sylvie
killed him then that would be you know the the
reason to prioritize her but there's also just
like this the leftover circumstances from last
time too with them being on this Manhunt anyway
um I wish the trailers didn't reveal that she
works at McDonald I know I know I would have love
to have almost no Sylvie in the trailers and then
to have this little post credit bit would have
been really nice I I personally only watched the
one trailer so I don't really know anything about
I only have those two things in my head the the
actor scene and the Sylvia McDonald's scene yeah
um well I wonder too if the if the the Rangers and
stuff are going to start encountering varians of
themselves who get to live you know or something
you know as they're going around I can't get
over they all going in such numbers like I don't
know maybe that's a possibility too man this is
brilliant I I can't get over the visuals of the
cosmic time Distortion the time waves and stuff
that's going to like stick with me that's that's
what the comics feel like and that was so cool
to see something that feels like a comic I've
read but like in a in a more tense 3D way yeah
yeah that was beautiful this is I mean this is
up there with my favorite uh first episode of
anything this is special this is one of the best
episodes of the Loki show confident confidently
say that yeah this is one of the absolute best
episodes of the Loki show I'm so glad Justin Aaron
on all of it like I'm so glad it's their show not
like you know switch around directors I'm sure
every people do great but this like this gives
me so much hope for the whole season yeah but and
what I just really appreciate too is the they are
providing a uniqueness here that feels that feels
different and distinct from season one and and it
and it still they still understand like turmoil
psychological turmoil like where moonight was
obviously very character focused uh which which
made more sense for that and here you still get
the emotionality of what everyone's experiencing
so there's still going to be character- based
stuff but it's more of about IMM mediacy of what
they're experiencing and the tension that they're
going through so I I really really I was really
impressed with this I I was surprised by how
it's like I had a feeling it would be good but
I didn't think it' be that good I know right I
actively didn't want it to end and I was Gob
smash like I don't I don't often get like I
don't have words and then I also don't want things
to not end Forever This Is Well it feels vintage
in throwback but also new you know like it feels
vintage it feels now and it feels future all at
the same time time time well and and part of me
I'm I'm curious too about what they're going to
do about that past beat that we saw with the you
know Kang statue uh because it's clear Mobius has
had his mind wiped number of times so I'm like is
there a recent previous iteration of the TVA that
was like Lord Kang Central or something yeah I
think that's what it seem to clearly establish
yeah at some point they didn't have to hide it
and like why did he start hiding it and and and
MOB is g to find out like some kind of horrible
complicitness that he's had to you know be a part
of in the past that he's not aware of now I also
there's a a strange parallel too to bring it back
to Obie Obie and he who remains you know like
they're both there with these really important
jobs about time displacement and whatnot they're
isolated and wait for visitors to come see yeah
he hasn't seen anyone in hundreds of years and he
seems fine too yeah I just I want more like he's
he's almost like a a supplement for Miss minutes
possibly I don't know uh it's something there's
something really interesting about a mirroring
effect with that see that's the magic is I'm like
I have so many you can draw theories out of this
there are so many Curiosities and they're all in
different directions there's the circumstances
of story but there's the character qualities
in that and and it's been a long time for me
since I've like coming into Loki season 2 is
like you know I'm happy to be here I loved the
first season so like this is a pretty easy bar
to clear like it can be you know if it's just
okay I would be honest about that but I would
be still pretty pleased to be here and so it's
been a long time since I've had that Vibe coming
in and then been so bold over like wow this went
far above and beyond any expectation I would have
had I'm happy enough to be back but also I'm
overjoyed that they like really pulled all the
stops out the Guardians for me I knew I'd love
it and then I was like who do I think is this
my favorite of the three if you look at what's
been beloved like our feelings for this I me I I
have a feeling people are going to love this yeah
sure um this Guardians director's Vision yes and
mostly isolated like mostly to itself not trying
to start 500 spin-offs yeah but you also know it's
connected at the same time without it like really
reaching for that connection like Loki season 1
and ju Division I think are the two most separate
of the shows and they did and here we are yeah
this is this is something really this felt very
special to me and this it's when you get [__]
like this of when you get something mediocre
of why mediocre thing in Marvel stings even
more right capable because you know what yeah you
know what the potential is and phase four people
dog on phase four but let's not forget it started
off with W division in Loki yeah W division Loki
no way home Shi came out of that it's just other
stuff did to and and then it's connective tissue
and the lack of consequent like this feels like
oh the repercussions the consequences of their
actions of the Loki's actions from the end of
season one and I think the benefit of this and
Kang and everything else is time travel does mean
you can clean that up like I do think Secret Wars
and Kang Dy mean like okay guys we hit Le listen
we read the message boards we're so sorry sweep
sweep and like this is totally a thing yet I
feel like the marketing for this and maybe it
has something to do with Jonathan Major's you know
personal life troubles uh it's been pretty Qui I
feel like the marketing for this has not been
ramped up as it normally would be for Marvel
I'm hoping but the word of mouth has got like I
know the trailer did phenomenally well but yet I
still feel like the marketing feels a little
quieter than usual sure yeah I agree I mean
I'm really curious how it ramps up and what word
amount is once it's out because I do think this
is exceptional and I think that quality is going
to make people that's why I said the first thing
like Marvel's back like I do think it's going to
be that kind of Rush and especially post Guardians
now they're two for two and so I hope this leads
to and the next thing after this is going to be
they're doing a whole day I think for um last we
heard heard they're doing everything at once with
Echo and then the Captain America 5 is the first
thing under iger's uh new St four yeah I skipped
a whole Captain America Captain America four is
the first thing under Marvel's whole scra four
entirely yeah we skipped four we're on to Sam
Wilson's five uh but yeah I think that you know
Bob iger's New Vision and like Kevin feige having
time to readjust to everything that had to be
changed with the pandemic and everything else like
remember Falcon Winter Soldier had to be like half
reshot like things had to really change with phase
four so I do have some faith in where we go from
here okay so I'm I'm very hopeful guys what did
you think about it uh I loved it absolutely loved
it a plus for me that is damn good Television
right there the best Marvel movie since the
Dark Knight is what Twitter will say easily truth
leave your thoughts down below thank you to all
who have been uh getting some RR apparel means
the world and we will catch you all very very
soon stay tuned for next week and whatever
else gets uploaded on this channel see you
guys